You.
You did not
testify in person in this trial.
There was a taped deposition of you
from October in it.
You defended the comments
that you made on that Access Hollywood
tape about being able to grab women
how you want.
Do you stand by those comments?
I said if you're famous
and rich or whatever.
I said, but I said of your star
you are.
And I said, women let you.
I didn't say you grew up.
I said, women
let you know you didn't use that word.
But if you look women let you now,
they said, will you take that back?
I said, look,
for a million years,
this is the way it's been.
I want to be honest.
This is where it's been.
I can take it back if you'd like to.
But if you're a famous person,
if you're a star
and I'm not referring to myself,
I'm saying
people that are famous, people that are
you are also in the deposition
people that are rich should be a star.
People that are powerful,
they tend to do pretty well
in a lot of different ways. Okay.
And you would like me to take that back?
I can't take it back.
Because it happens to be true.
I said it's been true
for 1 million years,
approximately a million years,
perhaps a little bit longer than that.
So you stand by those calls.
I don't want to lie, Mr. President.
Here's like here's
what you want to president.
Let's be rich and famous person
has no advantage over anyone else
where you do have an advantage.
And I say, unfortunately,
but that's the way it is.
You said
fortunately or unfortunately, fortunately
or unfortunately for her.